the guardian study links in utero
forever chemical exposure to low sperm
count and Mobility pfas now found in
nearly all umbilical cord blood around
the world interfere with hormones
crucial to testicle development could
this be why there are so many soy boys
they say
polyfluoro alkyl polyfluoro alcohol is
that you said yeah yeah substances are
known to disrupt hormones and Fetal
development and future reproductive
capacity is largely defined as defined
as testicles developed in utero during
the first trimester of a pregnancy said
study co-author Sandra sogard totenberg
I'm probably pronouncing that wrong of
the Copenhagen University Hospital quote
it makes sense that exposure to
substances that mimic and interfere with
hormones involved in this delicate
process can have consequences for semen
quality later in life yeah but if you're
talking about you know mangling up
somebody's uh somebody's voice while
they're in the womb isn't that going to
impact a lot more than that you know we
got a lot of soy boys with low sperm
counts could it be that these pfas
gumbels I was talking about this because
a lot of people
you know uh seemed seem to have
forgotten when Alex Jones came out and
said they were turning the frogs gay
it's talking about atrazine and
endocrine disruptors so I was saying
it's also pcbs and phthalates that
there's a bunch of studies showing that
those things can mess with people's
brains and development now we've got
this story this is from this is from
today on the guardian this new study
saying that these these chemicals
polyfluoroalkyl is how do you pronounce
it I don't know what I think so uh is
lowering sperm counts and I got to
imagine what you know the ubiquitous
chemicals are estimated to be 98 of
Americans blood and they can cross the
placental barrier and accumulate in the
growing fetus a recent analysis of 40
studies of umbilical cord blood from
around the world found that pfas were
detected in all three thirt 30 000
samples so someone want to look this up
what are these what is this chemical for
and why is it everywhere why is
everybody got it yeah well they're
called Forever chemicals because they're
impossible to get rid of and they keep
being persistent and there's no natural
way of them being filtered out or dealt
with this is why some people call them
forever chemicals and this is why some
scientists have labeled them this I try
to look up the nihs.gov page on it and
it says it no longer exists are you
getting that error well I got it I got
it here on Wikipedia per and polyfloral
alkyl substances
and uh it just explains what it is but
I'm wondering like why is it everywhere
you know like a lot of this a lot of a
lot of people can make us to to plastic
whoa look at this look at this and
non-stick chemicals yeah Teflon and or
aqueous film forming foam
so what what are we scraping the Teflon
off the pl the pans and yeah non-stick
pans and a lot of our packaging and a
lot of our consumer goods a lot of our
clothing also is is filled with a lot of
chemicals that absolutely affect us
there's pfas there's microplastics
there's other endocrine disruptors
there's seed oils there's people not
getting any kind of sunlight there's
vitamin deficient diets there's so many
things you could point to when it comes
to the destruction the the physical
destruction of the Modern Man and when I
when I tweeted this story I tweeted
there's a secret chemical War for your
balls your ball your balls are losing
and when you look at the rates of of
testosterone you look at the rates of
sperm counts dramatically declining in
dangerous levels to the point where
Jared kushner's comments could be
correct when he said we might live
forever or we might be the last people
to die because because people aren't
having children people can't have
children miscarriages are up
dramatically as well and this to me is a
part of the larger deep regulation
agenda that is also plaguing the world
right now I I think you know the mistake
that Jared Kushner made when he said
that he was you know going to live
forever be the last to die is that if
there's one thing you want to avoid when
you're hated by Millennial leftists is
Harry Potter references and you know
Voldemort was like only I can live
forever and so for Jared Kushner to go
on TV and say something like that it's
like dude they're already calling Trump
Voldemort you don't need to help them
out with the only cultural reference
they have right
I've been thinking about these pfas like
we're talking about uh perfluoroacle and
like I microwave plastic I probably
should stop doing it completely but yeah
like these bacon these single wrap
bacons and I put it in the microwave for
10 seconds and then eat it and it's like
just the the plastic is like rubberized
when I pull just eat the plastic it's
just just just take it all people are
finding plastic in people's lungs in
people's blood that's how far Plastics
have uh impacted Humanity that's that's
a level that is not normal that is not
okay that is affecting our human bodies
in very negative ways you know out of
all the chemicals I didn't hear anybody
mention bisphenol a and BPA was the
first thing to wake me up via Alex Jones
when I was working him with him in 2009
I think and I remember my girlfriend at
the time we were sitting there talking
and I brought it up and I said you know
this stuff is in our plastics it's
leaching it's in a lot of our canned
goods and she goes Jason I just I can't
they they no Jason they're not
feminizing people they would never do
that and you wonder yourself is this
part of a larger program to utilize
these chemicals in everyday products to
really change Humanity no I think it's
more likely that a company you know when
Plastics were first developed you got to
understand go to these antique shops
everything's metal and glass it's really
crazy to see a can of juice you know
it's like a big countdown oil can it's
like wow now everything is plastic these
days it's a lot cheaper it's a lot
easier to mold and then all of a sudden
they started saying like hey maybe this
is really really bad and you get these
wild water companies and they're sending
they're going so what are you telling me
well the phthalates and the plastic are
leaching into the water because it's
sitting for too long and you got
biophenols and polyphenols people are
ingesting it and it's causing problems
with their endocrine system and their
kids okay so what do we do you got to
get rid of the plastic you know that's
going to cost us billions of dollars we
can't afford that the company would
cease to exist how much to make the
study go away that what I think is more
likely is that there's too much
developed in the economy into using
Plastics nobody nobody's going to want
to go back to using metal everything
it's too heavy plastic super that's why
you need graphene because it's
lightweight carbon The Only Way Forward
is to get away from Plastics is to go
into graphene I think it'd be fine it's
the best way if all like we discovered
in like 70 years graphene leeches into
your water and then people are drinking
it well at least it's graphene is the
next lead well it's carbon it's not it's
not lead it's not pla it's I mean
Plastics are carbon based too but it's
just pure carbon so hopefully it's not
as bad
yeah and everything's got a downside to
it I think that Plastics are crazy I've
heard and I don't know if you guys can
confirm this that all the fluoride that
has been maybe not all but fluoride
being put in the water was partly
Industrial Waste they didn't know what
to do with the industrial fluoride waste
so they were just like just put it in
the water the aluminum waste conspiracy
theory aluminum wage it's the aluminum
waste because there's different types of
fluoride so you have uh stands at
fluoride and then you actually have a
calcium fluoride which is natural and
has very different properties so you can
drink water that has calcium fluoride in
it and it's not going to give you the
same effects as the aluminum byproduct
that you're talking about which is
um stands of fluoride so maybe those
were conflated in what I'd read I don't
know maybe they're putting the calcium
fluoride in the water well no I believe
that the calcium is only there naturally
in that whether I remember okay so we'll
go back to Infowars I remember when Rob
dou went to the Austin water plant and
the bags of the fluorides have the
death's head on them and anybody can go
watch those videos but it says look this
isn't a concentrated form this is
extremely deadly I'm not sure that we
would want to put that in uh water even
in a diluted form would we but somehow
we're doing that it's the most
electrically uh what's elastic chemical
uh element fluorine and that means it's
the most likely to take an electron away
from something else causing free radical
damage well also it's important to note
here that a lot of the hormones a lot of
the prescription drugs that a lot of
people are on uh especially when it
comes to things like birth control those
never really get filtered out there's no
way of kind of getting rid of those
chemicals and a lot of times public
drinking water is found to have
substances that are from Big Pharma that
were never filtered out that do have an
effect on human beings and I think that
also plays into the bigger role of
what's Happening Here when it comes to
the the chemical castration of the
modern man that is being chemically uh
and you know engineered
to uh be the way that the men are and I
think it's only going to get worse from
here I want to clarify uh fluorine is
the most electronegative element I think
electronegativity is a type of Electro
elasticity meaning that it's but
electronegativity means it's will it's
most likely to snag an electron away
from something and cause molecular
breakdown take a look at this graphic
the effects of of pfas
it includes low birth weight obesity
early puberty onset this is in babies
pregnancy-induced hypertension
preeclampsia increased time to pregnancy
low sperm count and Mobility increased
miscarriage risk and it negatively
impacts everybody else as well that
Wikipedia's got a study up here it's
actually an older study from from last
year February 2021 hormone disrupting
chemicals including pfas are linked with
rapid declines in human fertility
there you go baby and they call them
forever chemicals these pfas because
they and technically not forever but is
it larger in plastic
I don't know I stopped eating it I heard
horrible things about it yeah it is
horrible
margarine ingredients I mean
Mar is it true that margarine is almost
plastic
almost yeah uh it is not it's a
misinterpretation is that it is
chemically speaking yes margarine is
almost plastic because it has all the
same molecules as plastic except for one
but that isn't how organic compounds
work like literally anything margarine
is for my molecules since everything is
blah blah blah blah blah okay yeah I
don't know man I can tell the difference
between butter and margin butter and
margarine I think anybody can I think
everybody can one tastes bad and one
tastes good that's it but maybe the
quality of our store-bought butter is
just so awful that you know a lot of
people couldn't tell the difference
anymore but my thing is just stop eating
the fake stuff brominated what is that
you know brominated flowers or something
yeah you got potassium bromate uh yeah
what does that do it's like an evening
agent but also they found it in yoga
mats it's a chemical that causes what is
it like the fluffiness in yoga mats and
then they put in a bread it's banned in
France it's banned in a lot of Europe
I hear that's like it's like New York
Pizza has a ton of that stuff oh God and
I swear that when you make your own
bread I mean you just you digest it so
easy but a lot of that you don't know
who's got it I mean I can't look at like
Papa John's and maybe maybe you can find
the ingredients but like you get a pizza
box it doesn't say on the pizza box if
these potassium bromate and the bread
which it probably should we get you know
we got chickens and uh the eggs are all
just weird sizes you go to the store you
open up the egg thing and they're all
identical all white yeah you go in the
in the coop all these different chickens
some are like oblong some like we we've
had one I think whereas an egg and an
egg like that happens sometimes we have
a whole bunch of double yolks it's just
like they're all different ones like
copper brown one's green one's blue and
they're all shaped different in
different sizes and then I'm reading the
ingredients for like baking it's like
two large eggs and I'm like what does
that mean if you go to the store and
you're living in the modern world you're
getting this mass-produced generic crap
you open it all the eggs are the same
for me I'm like I don't know what two
eggs means these ones are big these ones
are small what am I supposed to give
many ounces of egg or something but I'm
just bringing this up because for one
you all know that I love chickens but
what I'm trying to say is you should be
doing what you can to eat as naturally
as possible we don't we don't have these
we do have plastic water bottles
but I make a point to buy glass water
bottles and we have Reef we typically
have reusable uh glass water bottles
that we fill up with our own filters
added minerals so we're on well water so
we don't got any gunk in it there's
natural Gunk that exists in well water
obviously but you filter it out it's got
this UV thing that the water passes
through killing all the bacteria and
then we put it in glass bottles and we
bring it up to the studio or we just get
these these aquapanna Toscana Italy
Italian water we're drinking Italian
water and glass bottles look at us huh
you know I got a fancy pants here but
but there's a big difference between
store-bought eggs and and eggs that you
naturally have from your own chickens
but you also should test your land for
lead if you are going to be eating those
eggs and to clarify potassium bromate is
not the stuff in yoga mats it's called
azodicarbonamide it's a dough
conditioner that also they put that in
our pizza they put uh it's an industrial
blowing agent azodicarbonamide known to
trigger asthma but then it's breakdown
it's it's the breakdown products of azo
dicarbamide
um
yeah it's in it's in dough as a
decarbonate of mine is a dough
conditioner it also is an industrial
blowing agent
yeah it's nastiest hydrogenated oils
it's just you got to get back to butter
and cream man oh I do like butter and
cream butter and cream yeah but so you
know Luke's been talking about seed oils
and all that stuff too you got the trans
fats you got hydrogenated oils and all
those other weird garbage there was this
place I remember it was an ice cream
shop I'm Gonna Keep the details vague
because I don't want to rag on them but
I go to this place and they say it was a
vegan it was it was vegan ice cream or
whatever and I was like oh what does
that mean and they said there's no dairy
in any of our ice cream you just get ice
cubes it was it was basically they took
Crisco hydrogenated vegetable shortening
with sugar and flavor and then churned
it and then it tastes good and so when I
when I was like what is it it's
basically like vegetable oil whipped and
Frozen I'm like that's gross yeah it I'm
gonna eat the cream from the cow and I'm
gonna enjoy it in New Hampshire they had
the exact opposite of that there's a
there's a farm where I usually stay at
that that has a bunch of cows that are
just running around not not in big
factories but are free to roam and they
have an ice cream place and they make
the ice cream from the raw milk from the
cows that are in the pasture and it is
like the most incredible ice cream you
could ever have there's pup cups that my
dog goes absolutely crazy for I I just
got her like a store but pup cup she
doesn't care she doesn't like it but but
that one with the raw milk she just went
raw milk is illegal well depends depends
on what you're doing with it if you're
trading it within state lines there's a
bunch of jurisdiction and bureaucracy
and government what they do out here and
but they passed the law in New Hampshire
where you could make ice cream out of it
and and and yeah what they do is you buy
a percentage of a co-op and now as an
owner you can have the raw milk and then
it's like you just gotta pay your share
or whatever so you as an owner you're
allowed to have it there's also what
they do is they sell it as pet milk
saying not for human consumption but
everybody else what that means so
they'll they'll tell you it's like oh
it's for pets and they'll grab it and
they'll just drink it it's like uh sure
whatever I mean for that matter you
could eat dog food it probably doesn't
taste good I wouldn't recommend it but
it's not I don't know probably shouldn't
but if you've got the Nanobots in your
brain and it tastes like ground beef so
so be it right it's going to have all
the nice little nutrients in it your
little dog food your pellets so here's a
question though
if is it a bad thing if you could
open up an app and make your bad food
taste like good food I mean is that bad
food actually good for you
physiologically well let's just say that
let's just say you've got have you ever
had Soylent
so I remember when Soylent first came
out and it was like I guess the name was
supposed to be a gag and the idea was to
make total meal replacement it's
impossible to do by the way because
humans are unique so what they realized
was when they put all of the stuff and
then oil into this one shake
if you're six foot five it's not going
to do it for you if you're five foot
five it might be too much but anyway
this stuff when it first came out tasted
like cardboard I'm not trying to be mean
it literally tasted like cardboard but
it had all these delicious nutrients
would it be a bad thing if you could
just be like press a button it taste
like a chocolate milkshake
that's tough you're getting good
nutrients everything you need all right
there and it's not made of people it's
just it was about it was like made of
oats and vitamins I mean that's the
question do you want to live in an
illusion or reality is that really an
illusion I mean you're getting your
nutrients and the reality is it tastes
great even though it doesn't taste great
unless you are I guess biochemically
changed you wouldn't want to flick the
switch on the neural link and then be
transported into Middle Earth where
you're battling you know a big fan of
reality Tim reality I'm a big fan of
reality I I listen I like the VR stuff
too I'm a video gamer as well hell I'm
replaying uh Saints Row 2 right now you
know for a little R and R but I think
when you get to the point where you can
no longer tell the difference between
what is reality and what is a virtual
environment you have many many ethical
questions that obviously run down to the
extremes of what the Matrix presents and
if you're going to do that with food in
particular you know how do you know all
that it's actually as healthy for you
unless you're getting your blood work
done every week or every month or we do
have the internet of bodies where
literally that program is running it you
don't know we've been lied to how many
times about what's in our food what's in
our medicines what's in the you know the
products that we use to keep up with our
hygiene such as just aluminum and
deodorants and that's on a micro level
so for me I'll take the real deal
anytime I'll take the delicious cream
Amish ice cream that I used to have in
Fort Plain and it was delicious like you
said you'd actually see them pour the
milk into the machine it would come out
and be like sweet and be like oh my
goodness I can't get this in a store
I think you can replicate a lot of
things but at the end of the day it's
really just a cheap imitation
almost everything in the supermarket is
trying to kill you that's what I say and
scream out loud as I'm walking through
the supermarket and be like hey this is
cancer this is going to kill you and
everyone's looking at me like I'm crazy
because I kind of am
but uh partly true I get these this Tech
is like bending your state of mind for
you so you don't have to do it yourself
like when you eat a food you can kind of
decide am I gonna let make myself enjoy
this or am I going to let myself find it
gross psilocybin mushrooms for instance
for me I know they grow on cow poop so
when I taste it it tastes like salty cow
poop I'm like oh well I'm gonna vomit
and I think about it it makes me
nauseous then I'm like no no it just
tastes like salty chewy goodness and I'm
tasting it it's like actually it's
really good so like the neural net can
do that for me but I have to override my
own sensual perceptions to force myself
to see it in a new way I think it's lazy
to rely on technology to do that for us
I already know what's gonna happen
it's going to be like 15 years from now
Ian's going to have like his hairs cut
really short he's wearing a suit me and
Luke are going to be like running
through a sewer with like you know
plasma rifles and then we're gonna we're
like running through it's like dark and
there's a little light shining down and
looks like go left left we turn left and
all sudden like a robot comes out and
then fires like it's fists and like
knocks us back Ian walks up from behind
us and goes stop running just accept it
and we're like Ian what happened to you
man and then he grabs us and he sticks
the neurolinker we're like no
my voice
oh geez did you ever read a wrinkle in
time I love that book it's my favorite
the youngest 20 something years the
youngest brother goes and interfaces
with the brain and then becomes part of
the brain and it's like man he's just is
the brain now it's completely taken over
him and don't they also have those kind
of fake environments when they go like
when the main character goes into the
City and everybody's kind of an
autonomous yeah yes yeah these are gray
and white and black and then but they
don't see it that way the people in the
brain and the Machine don't they see
gorgeous do you guys read the sequel to
it no no there's a sequel to it it was
one of those books they made us read
when we were kids yeah and I barely
remember any of it but I did read that
and then I think the sequel was called a
wind in the door or something like that
yeah wind at the door they made us they
made a movie and then nobody wanted to
see it yeah I I showed it to my nieces
but I couldn't get into it it had Oprah
in it it could be the interfacing with
the machine is like the one ring like I
think I can handle it I think I can go
in and then somehow help people break
out when the time is when the moment is
right but that I'll get get lost in it
and then people like you'll save I wake
up that's why Ian's gonna be chasing
down me and Luke as we're running
through the sewers like on the Darth
Vader character that thought I could
handle it and you guys are like no it's
too much no you're just like once you
have the neural link you'll understand
and then he grabs Luke and I'm like oh
no it looks like help and then he sticks
at Luke's neck and then looks like
everything is great Tim you'll enjoy it
too and I'm like no look thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there